DeForest Buckner of your NFC champion
49ers back here on the rich eyes and
show how are you sir I'm doing great
thank you for having me here oh come on
now you're in the Super Bowl I feel I'm
still soaking it all in
you know what I mean uh I mean it's just
it's crazy to think about you know what
I mean playing on I mean the world's one
of the world's biggest stages so I'm
still soaking it all in I mean so where
are you now in terms of tickets and
people calling you up walk me through
your your your world right now well I
mean uh last night I just got done
situating everything with my wife okay
um yeah I got ten family members coming
you know we have to you know figure out
flights and hotel and and all that but
it's it's all done it's all behind me
not focus on ball okay so did you have
to tighten the rotation here I mean just
ten right yeah yeah I mean just
immediate family from my side and and my
wife side so and then now and she and
then your wife is now the conduit for
everything you're just you're in the
bunker yo the father's DeForest bunker
basically the Buckner bunker so when you
get drafted you're drafted by the 49ers
into the Chip Kelly era and they had
just one and done two Tomsula going into
all that what what is it like now
compared to when you first got to the
49ers de Forest yeah it's completely
different um you know when I when I
first got in you know it was like locker
room wise just in the locker room in
general I mean I just felt like there
was you know clicked in the locker room
you know what I mean and you know I just
trying to navigate my way as a rookie
but you know the the guys that have been
brought in over the course of the past
three years
I mean you I love them all man you know
what I mean it's just one big
Brotherhood and that's just that's the
type of team that College on has been
building over the building over the past
three years just just you know a bunch
of a bunch of guys playing for each
other and a really good teammates man I
love them all and so what what
would you say is the the common theme on
all these teammates that have been
brought in that that has caused this
cohesive scenario obviously there's a
culture that that that a coach and a
general manager can build but what is
the I guess character trait that might
be similar here the Flores yeah honestly
everybody's I'm selfless you know what I
mean it's you know what we can do for
each other you know what I mean
when when things are going wrong or bad
or any of that nobody points fingers
everybody's trying to figure out what
they can do to to help the team and
that's my biggest thing I pull for me
you know I don't I don't see any selfish
guys in the locker room that are you
know Karen they don't care about you
know personal stats all this kind of
stuff it's what they can do you know to
the best of their abilities to help the
team DeForest Buckner 49ers defensive
lineman here on the Rich Eisen show and
then obviously before John and then when
John got there to just constantly
hitting the defensive line with first
overall selections well certainly for a
team but first round selections you were
one of that and and this group together
let's discuss your group together and
what makes you guys click so well yeah
obviously we knew especially in the
beginning of season that a lot was
invested in in our room you know what I
mean with the you know the high draft
picks you know bringing D in and all of
that and so we we know we know how how
much was invested into our room and we
knew that um to go as far as we wanted
to go that we would be a big part of it
and we had to you know with the own up
to that challenge and we had to you know
meet expect expectations and just going
into the season you know in the hall you
know OTAs and training camp we we wanted
to be one of the hardest working groups
and and to kind of set the tempo you
know for you know practice whatever it
was and and a big part of that is
Christmas er you know come bringing
Chris in and helping us out you know
bringing us you know a whole nother
level has been phenomenal for the group
and you can just see it on Sundays they
add you we play with nu and Solomon
Thomas and
and Armstead and Bosa you know you guys
have all accounted for eight of the nine
sacks this postseason the first the guys
who are taken in the first round I don't
know if you're aware of all that how
will they pay to do that now it's my job
to do it I guess
but it's also my job in the media to try
and make you collective as a as a
defensive line group into a unit that we
can just call by one name I know you
don't have a nickname right as a unit
correct we don't did Dee Ford pass along
to you the one that I put forth to him
for all of you did he mention it to you
he did not mention it what does it mean
come on now I know you had an NFC
Championship game you get ready for but
what's the Fermi's Dee Ford is just
slacking on the job
here it is DeForest okay okay let's hear
let's hear the gold crush the gold crush
okay okay you know it has a little ring
to it you know I mean yeah okay no I
know you're you're a young guy but the
Denver defense back in the 80s and 90s
was the Orange Crush
okay all right and hear me out here
the cheerleaders that you have is the
gold rush right you're the gold gold
crush okay you see what I'm saying yeah
that might might just stick I might just
they're not just saying that to me
because you know I'm not just saying
that you know I have to you know has to
get passed through the board you know
what I mean so I'll throw it around when
he knows dee dee dropped the ball okay
you divorce Buckner you need to carry
this rock into your room I got you okay
if you don't mind
make it happen all right all right it
wouldn't it truly it's and this might
speak to Who I am as a person and what
I've got going on for me this would make
my world it really would it would just
if I could name you guys as a unit the
gold crush okay
I look forward to you going to the
podium at media night on Monday know
what you know what we I wish for you all
to call us the gold crush all right we
gotta get it passed through the board
though what was the board whose support
who's the boy the entire D line so Bose
Bose is not gonna go with a Michigan guy
I'm screwed just cause it's coming from
me he just won't do it on principle that
that might be that might be true but
we'll see all right how's he been
Nick what's he added to this mix brother
oh he's he's been phenomenal you know
what I mean II as a young guy you forget
that he's a rookie honestly the way he
carries himself he prepares himself for
the game I mean he's a true Pro and you
know it's great because because you know
I could still learn learn things from
him on a daily basis you know what I
mean and you know we just like to you
know run ideas by each other you know
he's he's an open book so is everybody
else on the d-line and to have a player
like him at his caliber you know in our
group I mean it's it's a blessing man to
have you know him and the Eric Salomon
we can go you can whole list of names on
the line you know what I mean that you
know everybody is just comfortable with
each other and you know we could run
ideas by each other and we just pray for
each other so it's just it's a great
group fall around DeForest Buckner here
on the Rich Eisen show and now comes
what a challenge for you in front of you
in Patrick mahomes who has just a few
days left as the reigning MVP of our
league and his ability to stretch a play
and then throw to virtually anybody at
any point on the field if you can't get
to him in time I wonder what you think
of this challenge in front of you with
him no yeah the guy's a superstar um you
know he is cannon for an arm you know he
really accurate obvious obviously cancer
anywhere on the field and his ability to
extend plays is you know on a whole
nother level so you know I'm as a group
we got to do a really good job with
containing them in the pocket um and
really getting after them early and and
also rallying to you know all the
screens and you know the quick game that
they do so
we just need a B on our piece in our Q's
and also just contain the speed that
they have you know receiver obviously
there they have a lot of weapons on the
outside and you know and I running back
so we just have a really good overall
job with containing their speed well
prior to this obviously you had Lamar
Jackson in your sights earlier this year
and I imagine that was a challenge but
I'm what would you say is similar to the
one I'm wondering what what what you'd
never take out of that experience oh
yeah Lamar obviously he's a whole nother
speed on different different playing
styles you know what I mean there's he's
more of a legit running back at
quarterback you know what I mean and
it's a different game plan you know this
especially dealing with that type of
offense but um I mean it you could take
things away with you know obviously
trying to contain them in the pocket and
and all that kind of and in that sense
though and his ability to extend play so
it's still similar traits but I feel
like you know different different type
of players well it's definitely the
offenses aren't different you know parts
of our football universe in terms of of
their styles and strength and ability to
put points on the board they both can do
that they just have different methods in
which to get there go to that spot I
just wanted to just try just a mirror
aspect of when can you hit a quarterback
or not like you is this guy a runner or
not and and and my homes is run at the
end of the first half against Brighton's
it's been put in front front and center
and as the latest example of a defender
not really wondering when you can hit a
quarterback or not and suddenly he's 20
yards down the field I wonder what you
think ya know exactly you know you know
hopefully as he watches film throughout
this past two weeks leading up to the
game you know he can see that uh what
our defense or we're pretty fast defense
we like to swarm and you know I'm
watching watching the film he would take
a financial decision in running out of
bounds or sliding
I love the way you just put that like
you tiptoe down that sideline yourself
with your words right there that was
phenomenal there are business decisions
that you and the rest of the gold crush
force see how I used in a sense right
exactly yeah okay so when do you when do
you I guess get into the film room
what's your schedule this week you know
we have a pretty normal week okay I mean
I'm watching nobody there watching film
today yeah you're already there oh yeah
they they got it uploaded on our iPads
you know this is so exciting I mean I
I'm glad that you you and your your
family are situated already and the
logistics are handled because that's for
the 20 years I've closed I've done this
it seems can really turn some people
around so you know and then now you can
just focus on everything this is
exciting for you before I let you go
Justin Herbert we saw what he did in the
in the Rose Bowl how effective you think
he can be at this next level as we
turned the page towards the draft for 30
other teams before yeah I think he is a
he's a great quarterback he he is the
size you know what I mean I'm here he
has a leg leg talent and I mean he has a
cannon for an arm so I honestly think he
you do really what this level and um you
know obviously hopefully a team to help
him develop as a player and you know I'm
excited to see where he goes in the
draft
yeah I'm I think you know he's got all
the talent in the world but I just
figured you know you want to talk about
another duck before I let you go thanks
thank you for the time to forest I
really appreciate it I know you got a
lot going on you're spinning plates now
and getting ready for your biggest game
of your life and your career there good
luck in it I hope I crossed paths with
you down in Miami I really appreciate
the call I yeah I appreciate that they
you for having me again ripped right
back at you that's the forest Buckner at
DeForest Buckner on Twitter for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app